good evening i'm denise valdez and i'm
brian loftis another ccsd educator has
been arrested this is now the second
time second person to be taken in
custody in less than a week the most
recent case was a month long
investigation that involved police from
out of state marco manna is our newsroom
tonight with more on the message from
one parent after learning about what
happened orca well denise and brian
we've learned the investigation into
jennifer cortad started back in october
2020 and the arrest point was issued
this august she was taken into custody
by police in utah and booked into ccdc
over the weekend although she's been
caught many are asking how ccsd will
ensure this does not happen again
youth with special needs are probably
one of the most vulnerable populations
linda tasche's son grant has autism and
although he's graduated from ccsd seeing
a school district employee who works
with special needs students get arrested
for sex crimes is alarming it really
breaks my heart when i hear that these
children are getting taken advantage of
ccsd police arrested 48-year-old
jennifer cortad on two counts of
statutory seduction the arrest stems
from an investigation that started at el
dorado high school in october 2020 ccsd
police say cortad worked as an
occupational therapist since august 2014
and according to a ccsd job description
that role involves working with students
with disabilities cashe says ccsd should
do more to protect students the school
district has a responsibility i asked
ccsd how they vet their employees they
sent me a statement saying in part
district staff run background checks on
all employees this includes fbi
background checks with fingerprinting
but tache who runs her own organization
that helps children with developmental
disabilities says check-ins should be
ongoing monitoring more closely and more
frequently cashe even points to
previously failed legislation that would
put cameras in classrooms i think that
maybe we need to revisit it next session
now anyone who believes they or their
child had inappropriate contact with
corted is asked to call ccsc police
that's the number there at the bottom of
your screen reporting live in the
newsroom tonight orco mana live local
now